in the hours before this summit the host
french president emmanuel macron and the
german chancellor olaf schultz spoke by
telephone with president putin
after that call president macron said he
was depressed and worried today when i
look at the facts
let's be lucid the facts are the
following
russia
decided to launch a war russia is
bombing ukraine russia is bombing even
civilians
and in parallel you have a negotiation
but this negotiation
is
not ready to be concluded the response
to this crisis by the eu has so far been
united and strong
but there are different views on what to
do next
some like the latvian prime minister
christianis karens want the sanctions
extended to the energy sector we have to
not only isolate putin's economy but
[ __ ] the economy as quickly as we can
ukraine wants the eu to give it
fast-track membership but many leaders
here believe that's a non-starter i want
to focus on what can we do for voldemort
zielinski tonight tomorrow and and eu
accession of ukraine is something for
the long term if at all the talks went
on into the night and will continue
later on friday but it's clear ukraine
is not going to get what it wanted a
fast-track route to eu membership james
bay's al jazeera versailles